Hongkong 2019
und 2023
wie sehr kann sich eine Stadt in vier
Jahren verändern
was ist aus den bis zu 2 Millionen
Menschen geworden die damals auf die
Straße gegen um für Freiheitsrechte zu
demonstrieren
[Musik]
jedes Mal wenn ich hier hinkomme
erinnert es mich daran dass Dinge
passiert sind die nicht vergessen werden
sollten
Chloris führt uns an den Ort an dem er
2019 verhaftet wurde so wie mehr als
10.000 andere
im Prozess konnten sie nichts anderes
beweisen
nur dass ich mich hinter dieser Säule
versteckte und dass ich Ausrüstung am
Körper hatte
[Musik]
helmhandschuhe und Maske ein Foto zu
zeigen ist ihm zu riskant denn er wurde
als Unterstützer des Aufruhrs verurteilt
32 Monate lang saß er im Gefängnis noch
heute fühlte sich hier unwohl Beziehung
ist CCTV diese Überwachungskameras
erinnern daran dass es nicht sicher ist
hier so offen zu sprechen
[Musik]
sollten wir besser gehen ja
am nächsten Morgen empfängt uns der
32-Jährige in seinem Obstladen er hat
ein eigenes Geschäft eröffnet denn mit
der Lücke die die Gefängniszeit in
seinem Lebenslauf hinterlassen hat ist
es nicht einfach einen Job zu finden
guten Morgen Ich heiße course
seine Haft hat er genutzt um Sprachen zu
lernen die könnten ihm auch helfen sich
woanders ein neues Leben aufzubauen
Claris wählt seine Worte vorsichtig er
will reden solange er noch kann
mit jedem Interview riskiere ich
gewissermaßen noch mal mein Leben noch
mal ins Gefängnis zu gehen
denn mit dem sogenannten
Sicherheitsgesetz kann seit 2020 nahezu
alles bestraft werden was als Kritik an
der Kommunistischen Partei ausgelegt
werden kann
für die prochinesische Politikerin
Regina yipp war das Gesetz eine
angemessene Reaktion auf die Proteste
die Gewalt wurde inakzeptabel also er
ließ Peking in unserem Namen eingesetzt
zur nationalen Sicherheit ist diente
nicht dazu die Demonstranten loszuwerden
sondern um recht Ordnung Harmonie und
Stabilität wiederherzustellen
auch ihre Arbeit im Parlament sei
einfacher seitdem viele pro
demokratische Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nicht mehr da sind
viel effektiver effizienter ohne die
verschleppungstaktik und die
absichtliche Behinderung durch die die
der Westen gerne als Demokraten
romantisiert sie haben Hongkong viel
Schaden zugefügt
dazu würde sie vielleicht auch die Frau
zählen die wir 40 Minuten von Hongkongs
Stadtzentrum entfernt treffen
der BI ließ sich hier als Bezirksrätin
wählen doch nach zwei Jahren trat sie
zurück
alle Bezirksräte sollten plötzlich einen
Eid ablegen um zu schwören dass wir der
Kommunistischen Partei gegenüber loyal
sind
wie viele andere machte Debbie das nicht
um für ihre Wählerinnen und Wähler
trotzdem weiter ansprechbar zu sein
behielt sie ihr Büro sie verkauft lokale
Produkte um die Miete zu decken das Geld
reicht nie doch diesen Monat hatte sie
plötzlich einen Rekordumsatz
Ende Mai fing ich an Kerzen für den 4
juni zu verteilen es ist eine Tradition
der hongkonga um für die Menschen zu
trauern die an diesem Tag gestorben sind
an dem Tag an dem das chinesische
Militär 1989 auf dem tennamenplatz in
Peking die demokratieproteste blutig
niederschlug in China sind die Toten
sogar das Datum ein Tabu Derby hat
protokolliert was dann geschah
sie bekam Besuch von der Lokalregierung
Leute hätten sich beschwert dass ihr
Bücherregal den Fußweg blockiere oder
sie Alkohol an Minderjährige verkaufe
plötzlich kamen diese verschiedenen
Behörden alle innerhalb von zwei drei
Tagen was doch sehr ungewöhnlich ist
seither kommen so viele Leute wie nie in
ihrem Laden es ist diese Art von stillem
Protest der in Hongkong noch möglich ist
während unseres Besuchs hält plötzlich
ein Polizeiauto gegenüber die Beamten
machen Fotos von uns Derby fotografiert
zurück neue Normalität in Hongkong
ich glaube nicht dass die Menschen in
Hongkong glücklich über die Situation
sind aber sie haben auch das Gefühl dass
das gefährlich ist etwas darüber zu
sagen
so erklärt ist der Sozialwissenschaftler
der wie so viele andere von Hongkong
nach Großbritannien flüchtete nachdem er
mehrfach von der Polizei vorgeladen
wurde beschloss er zu gehen um weiter
aussprechen zu können was er in Hongkong
nicht mehr sagen kann wie hat uns wurde
gesagt wir müssen die roten Linien
einhalten aber wir wussten nie wo die
roten Linien sind
schon ein Lied zu singen kann in
Hongkong heute gefährlich sein
glory to Hongkong die Hymne der
Protestbewegung von 2019 will die
Regierung gleich komplett verbieten
geht es nach Peking soll Hongkong zu
einer normalen chinesischen Stadt werden
[Musik]